thank you alejandro first of all sam big
congratulations this is probably one of
your biggest victory in terms of a match
victory against such a stable and one of
the leading players of american trust
wesley so how does that feel oh yeah
definitely my biggest match victory i've
had so far
i prepared very well for this match
since the pairings came out pretty much
at the start of april
uh yesterday it went my way and today
he chose a very solid opening probably
wanted to play a long game were you
surprised by that by his opening choice
would you expect something like the
king's indian or anything of that nature
i thought he would play something solid
um because he generally doesn't play
stuff like king's indian
and that's what he said as well he just
simply doesn't have it within his
brother yeah he just didn't doesn't play
these sharp crazy openings
how important is it for you that with
this game you just officially crossed at
least on the live rating list 2700
uh well i've been working for this for a
long time now but
after
one goal is achieved you move on to the
next one and which one is that what is
your next goal
well next would be 27.50 27.50 it is
let's go through the game
uh what moment would you like to look at
we felt
sam as probably you did as well that
once you achieve your pawn on h6
it's all one-way traffic and
everything's going in your favor is that
the way you felt yeah absolutely um he
probably should have played bishop f5
earlier to be able to meet this h5
bishop d3 idea with bishop e6 h6 for
example here bishop f5 that's what he
expressed as well uh sam that bishop f5
was the moment where
he should be able to meet h5 with h
right at least now when he plays h6 he
has interesting plans to play like f5
knight f6 with the idea of 94
i probably wouldn't actually play h5 in
this scenario
um
maybe long i'm not sure yeah because f5
is coming now
yeah
so
did
this was
basically the crucial moment yeah and
later you did get this
what we thought was a very very nice
advantage
you felt you were close to winning at
this point uh
no i definitely never felt i was winning
because of this knight b6 knight c86
idea
which i definitely like white but i'm
not sure how to break through because
he quickly plays f5 bishop and tries to
get rid of this h6 pawn
um i'm definitely better in the final
position right but
i decided to conserve some energy
true that there was this one incredibly
beautiful methodical game it was anatoly
karpov of anderson
you could take this the the pawn on b2
put it on c5 it was this double rook
ending that anatoly won
and this is just
a beautiful beautiful game
and
like you said you could torture him if
you wanted to
but it's it's definitely a very big
advantage for you
yeah actually he mentioned a good move
here uh instead of rook f5
you can play
basically black wants to play rook takes
e5 d6 you have f6 if i allow it which is
why i pretty much just repeat it here
yes but a nice idea is to play king d3
to be able to meet this with king d4 at
the end
oh
that is cute that is very cute
that's strong yeah no not on time to
place b65 yeah yeah b6 we could always
play b4
um
yeah it's definitely one-way traffic
here exactly exactly
well uh seriously uh hardy
congratulations on joining the 2700 club
remember it's not that you just get
there but you maintain it
you know
and like you say it's 27.50 and it's all
about playing in well the grand chess
tour playing against the best players in
the world making fighting your way to
the candidates and we'll certainly be
rooting for you to achieve all your
goals good luck in the rest of the
tournament thank you
absolutely sam savion